[Música]
amanhã conto uma história
não vou contar nada hoje vamos contar a
minha mas tudo isso aconteça ou
aconteceu hoje
é curioso porque nos programas que você
já tiveram acesso às vezes aparece
acontece é todavia nós temos aqui é
quando seu hoje que aconteceu hoje um
conjunto de histórias serão contadas
precisamente a minha
e nessas histórias nós somos os
protagonistas
portanto isto quer dizer que tudo que
ouvimos falar pelos oradores entre
outros desde a filosofia desde questões
deve ver o futuro com questões médicas
desde a questão propriamente dita do
jornalismo da importância dos
jornalistas de divulgarem precisamente
aquilo que é hoje das dificuldades do
hoje que nós todos temos um conjunto de
informação diariamente seja por jornais
seja planeta ea questão de fiabilidade
dessa mesma informação que é muito
importante e depois temos percebido é
questão do ensino da importância do
ensino para as gerações futuras da
capacidade que nós temos de inovar e de
aprender
temos uma questão fundamental somos nós
as pessoas que estamos hoje nós somos um
dos protagonistas da nossa história da
nossa história local da nossa história
regional que por sua vez se transpõe
para a história nacional devido aos
acontecimentos independentemente e cada
vez mais estamos numa história mas vale
na velha história do pai é uma história
mundial
agora taparem bem nas calda uma pessoa
que vive no interior do nosso país
o objecto da sua história onde ela se
encaixa na história mundial
estamos apenas uma pequena formiguinha
podemos dizer assim um grande formiga
irão e portanto cada um de nós tem o seu
trabalho diário de sua vida suas pessoas
das suas relações
visto muitas vezes faz parte entre os
amigos da nossa história
essa história precisa naturalmente se
contava ela faz parte da nossa
capacidade ou da nossa identidade seja
uma identidade no causa de uma
identidade digamos nacional a nossa
pátria
como dizia fernando pessoa a nossa
pátria é a língua portuguesa
mais do que isso nós somos portugueses
não tinah território que precisamos
nessa mesma história para nos
identificarmos hora ao longo da nossa
história
digamos recente dos últimos dois três
séculos a história provavelmente
internacional tem vindo a desenvolver se
com outro aspecto que a história local a
história das pessoas e daí surgirem as
chamadas monografias as juntas de
freguesia ou escamas procurar evidenciar
a história de vida das pessoas
a gastronomia os monumentos tipo dizer
história contínua aconteceram com a
chance de vivenciar as evidências mais
importantes de um determinado local
e tudo isto para potenciar a uma
localidade para nos criar identidade
por isso é que muitas vezes nós pensamos
o que nós temos de bom para mostrar às
pessoas
hoje temos uma coisa muito boa que o
tedh x ou tv
isto vai ser a nossa história da mente é
a menina será contada nas redes sociais
será contada nos jornais será contada em
nível nacional quem sabe através de
várias idéias jornalísticas
tivemos aqui o jornalista quem sabe não
se não irá fazer entrevistas me adiantou
sérgio da importância e isso fará parte
ou não da nossa história uma espera
fazer parte da nossa história precisa
alguém que como eu tenho sido um que num
treino que nem formiga neste aspecto a
contar a nossa história
caímos província que conta a história
cai no caso não é um pecado mortal nos e
quase é contar a história que nós
identificamos em documentos que nós
identificamos nas pessoas mas a minha
história pode não ser
história outra história porque a maneira
de contar essa história tem muito a ver
com a pessoa e portanto eu quando conto
uma história num livro é com base na
minha experiência nos momentos de
encontro na minha capacidade de moldar
essa história para nos transmitir ao
euro e tudo isto por vezes tem um
aspecto hoje em dia que o espeto
turístico numa região
nós vamos pensar agora um vídeo pra
vocês vêem essa importância da história
é um vídeo precisamente do turismo
centro que eu fui buscar a este outro
precisamos mesmo estrangeiro
a missão expira time que atualmente roda
hoje jorge plan anytime theofanes
eckstein conhecia irã ganhou mikandi
volte ao estoque luva capacete o céu
tampa rápida na estreia no dragão
a mesa decidiu que o réu sofre uma nova
perspectiva em roswell não sabe dano e
os em pleno ronco ex
[Música]
tem sido dominante se caminha vírus
hangar 18 100 só sou ensino gogh ram
primeiro os pixels sai do ex-prefeito
uns picaretas em roma
tenho 66 anos que existe no treino
matinal ou twitter
além de roubar capacete jones bons só
come se coloca assim a nota chama sempre
bahia
é um filme e outro sócio é essa john's
comenda adam mata rolim gueiros pior
confronto em natal é vovós a web a morte
tons acerto terá white fez um dom jorge
mota ainda mais um mito roni horas
admitiu branca
skate em espanha entre eles o sambô
ideal é tão ruim blue instruir os céus é
exploding ele escavava bonita
touchscreens grande sim dá pelo ar
eles nutrem indiquem que o mal
cospe life to de volta erradas disse
kleiman não
[Música]
quem desenha ré stosur antes de pôr fim
nos cuidar sim china friday o estatuto
orientações também olha essas mães
o vulcão shinmoe dias gigantes quepe
obriguei esatr ou clássica blog
[Música]
vocês vão ver é precisamente o momento e
nós temos pensar que a história precisa
muito do momento e nós devemos ver que
de momento nunca devemos olhar para trás
por trás o passado é o passado serve
para compreender o futuro mas serve para
viver o presente
nós temos um exemplo perfeito de esse
presente é precisamente a paixão que uma
garotinha por esta localidade e portanto
nós temos cinco contar a história do
maior mas temos que pensar na história
de uma viúva como alguém que se
apaixonou por alvo foi a nossa paisagem
foi às pessoas e que viveu precisamento
que de momento e vivia tão intensamente
que os merkava em cada quatro
e quando nós vamos focar no quadro
melhorou a estamos a ver agora estamos a
ver pessoas
estamos a ver o nosso passado eo melhor
quis marcar precisamente é marca do
nosso passado e deixou uma mensagem que
foi a mensagem mais bonita que nós
podemos ter a nossa região que a nossa
riqueza paisagística a nossa cor as
nossas pessoas
o nosso inglaterra
e isso em nossa história e contar essa
história geração em geração é o que tem
vindo a fazer mas tem que ser pensado em
ser cuidava e preservada no sentido de
nós próprios vivemos nos apaixonamos por
nossa região
muitas vezes nos convidam a ir ver um
amigo haver um museu numa cidade ou
percorrerá x quilômetros prever um
quadro em nós não conhecemos a nossa
região nós não conhecemos as cascatas
por exemplo maravilhosas d'água alta
nós não conhecemos o mexer dos rios aqui
bem perto de ser do sol entre nada os
pontos altos das nossas serras e às
vezes buscamos algo mais tantos buscando
somar buscamos o infinito e precisa
manter essas mensagens têm sido através
da história
invertidas o que nós procuramos muitas
vezes o que mente
nestes tempos modernos na história é
olhar não pro mar mas olha o interior é
que o interior muitas vezes as pessoas
dizem está deserto
eu não estava certo tom k pessoas são
suficientes ou não são os que estão e
são essas pessoas que vivem este
presente
essa é a nossa história a história de
que os questão e continua a acreditar
que vale a pena gastar e que vale a pena
olhar para o mar mas temos que cativar
aquelas que estão no mar virou interior
não é por qualquer motivo que por
exemplo o 31 centro ganhou um prêmio
precisamente é dar razão a nossa
história e o papel do treinador é mesmo
este é dar valências rodar ou potenciar
ou é apontar caminhos para que o papel
seja das autarquias
o papel de dez pessoas privadas portanto
a parte pública parte privada de
potenciar ou de cativar todos aqueles
que viram interior
esse é o papel muitas vezes não
historiador que está encoberto nesta
história é contar algo nós contamos com
um treinador sentiu
vamos procurar o porquê daquele edifício
quando vamos a uma localidade vamos
procurar uma igreja vamos procurar um
museu
vamos observar a nossa história ea nossa
história não é só isso é um aspecto
gastronômico é o folclore e música é um
aspeto social é o aspecto econômico tudo
isso que nossa história e nós não
devemos nunca pensarmos num passado que
já pensou num futuro que ainda não vai
o que está para vir nós vamos pensar no
nosso presente e neste presente vamos
terminar vendo um vídeo foi precisamente
esse ganho um prémio que olhar com entre
o que muitas vezes nós próprios que
estamos no ônibus eo papel do
historiador proveito e despertar isso
despertar a curiosidade
nós temos e despertando a curiosidade
traz o aspecto mais positivo que hoje
portugal aposta é no turismo nos
turistas
captação de investimento captar o olhar
o interior mas acima de tudo para que
quem cá está viva
precisamente o momento eo momento é
agora
agora o nosso vento irá ser contava a
minha e por isso nem é quanto uma
história
vamos ver outro vídeo
[Música]
a enfam dt foi william e harry bairro
jardins mesclei a 22
é no old serejo as células rogers é de
turismo durante móveis têxteis leandro
quem os incluindo os fred vai estimulá
los ao canal atb oeste
house é o português katy hayward até
franco anos que marlos reclame shutdown
a isso a rua euros em 2001 o ex plantios
carro
ae antes o ele pergunta o adilson é um
cerco e pôs o dia no eixo sul média
randall ã o do castigo de junho e foi
noivo os 58 entre o trecho morro é novo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o haiti luiz adriano willian ativos de
sangue
a ponte do ó
[Música]
o juiz mãos entrou portugal canto e eu
sei bem que esta aposta no centro de
portugal na nossa história onde cada um
faz parte da história
precisamos viver o momento e portanto o
papel cada vez mais da história local da
história regional é precisamente
evidenciar os acontecimentos sejam menos
assentos sejam repassados para fixar
população para cativar a população mas
acima de tudo para propriamente as
pessoas sentirem que esta é nossa terra
o nosso território e aqui o território
que amamos este nossa história
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]